[موسيقى]
نحن هنا في مسرح TCL الصيني في
منزل هوليوود لجميع العروض السينمائية الكبيرة
الأولى منذ عام 1927 ، وقد تم بناء المسرح في
الأصل في عام 1927 من قبل سيد
غرومان ، لقد كان
رجل العرض الرئيسي في هوليوود الذي أراد أن يقدمه للجمهور
الذي جاء عبر أبوابنا و  الهروب
من الواقع منذ اللحظة التي تخطو فيها
داخل الأبواب الذهبية
لمسرح TCL الصيني ، سيتم
نقلك إلى وقت مختلف في مكان مختلف
، تم تصميم كل شيء عن المسرح
ليكون صينيًا فريدًا في
هندسته المعمارية.
في المقدمة ، على سبيل المثال ، تلك هي في
الواقع كلاب Ming Dynasty Heaven الأصلية
التي يعود تاريخها إلى القرن السادس عشر في عهد أسرة Ming في
الصين ، وقد تم رسم العمل الفني داخل
الردهة الرئيسية في الأصل من
قبل الممثل والرسام الأمريكي الصيني
ki Luke داخل القاعة الرئيسية
نفسها ، وهو العمل الفني على
السقف المظلم الذي شعر  القصة الجميلة
كلها توزع قوالب الإستنسل الخاصة بمكتبهم والتي
أنشأها رجل يدعى جون بيكمان
وهي مبنية بشكل فضفاض على  قصة
صبي صغير يصبح أميرًا ، العمل الفني على
الجدران الجانبية داخل القاعة
رسمه كزافييه كوجات كزافييه كوجات ،
المعروف جيدًا باسم
قائد الفرقة الموسيقية ، وكان أيضًا رسامًا ورسام
الكاريكاتير لدينا وجلس استأجره
للرسم  كل هذا العمل الفني هناك في الواقع
في عام 1927
[موسيقى]
كان المسرح الصيني TCL أول
مسرح سينمائي يستضيف جوائز الأوسكار
فازت الدار البيضاء بجائزة أفضل صورة هنا مرة أخرى في عام
1944 في حفل توزيع جوائز الأوسكار السنوي السادس عشر
منذ ذلك الوقت كان لدينا أفلام يتم عرضها
هنا  والعرض الأول هنا بدءًا من
أفلام مثل Star Wars Titanic الذي تم
عرضه لأول مرة هنا ، لقد كان لدينا العرض الأول هنا
لـ Mary Poppins ، يعد TCL Chinese Theatre في
الواقع أطول
مسرح سينمائي تجاري ذو شاشة واحدة في
البلاد ، لذا يمكنك الجلوس في نفس
المقعد الذي كانت جودي جارلاند  حزين أو
نفس المقعد الذي جلست عليه جينيفر لورانس
مؤخرًا أو نفس المقعد الذي كان كيانو
ريفز من الساتان أو أي شخص يمكن
أن تفكر فيه في جيمي ستيوارت همفري
بوغارت أو ماكول مرة أخرى ، أي نجم يمكن أن
يخطر ببالك كان على الأرجح هنا
احتفالات اليد والبصمة التي
تعود الآن إلى افتتاح
المسرح في عام 1927 منذ ذلك
الوقت ، قمنا بتكريم الجميع بدءًا من
جيم كاري إلى جاك  لقد أجرينا
هنا بصمات يد لنيكلسون لشيرلي تمبل
من ستيف ماكوين إلى فريق عمل Hunger
Games فريق هاري بوتر
لدينا مخرجان من ستيفن
سبيلبرغ وجورج لوكاس مخرجان
مثل رون هوارد لدينا جولات هنا
إلى حد كبير  يتم إجراؤها يوميًا
من حوالي الساعة التاسعة صباحًا
على طول الطريق خلال ساعات الليل
وهذا النوع من جولة المشي لمدة 30 دقيقة
التي نأخذك في الواقع إلى الداخل لإخبارك
بتاريخ المسرح الذي
ستشاهده من الأفلام التي تحتوي على  تم
عرضه هنا أو حتى تم عرضه لأول مرة هنا على مدار
92 عامًا الماضية ، إنها حقًا واحدة من
أكثر المشاهد شهرة في هوليوود وفي
جنوب كاليفورنيا ، إنها
تجربة مدهشة للغاية لا
تريدها  عندما تكون هنا في وسط
هوليوود
أنت